- All we are back.
And you may remember earlier this season
we welcomed the cast of "Black Adam,"
Dwayne Johnson, Noah
Centineo, Aldis Hodge,
Quintessa Swindell, and Pierce Brosnan,
amazing group of actors.
It was fun show and we
had a lot to chat about
and it all couldn't fit
into our original episode.
In fact, we actually did a round
of the ultimate Twitter
questionnaire during which
they answered some pretty
interesting fan questions.
We didn't want you to miss
any of it, so check this out.
Okay, here we go.
(bell dings)
Okay.
Oh, this is for Aldis.
So rumor has it that The Rock called you
to tell you that you got the role.
Is is there any truth to that?
Wait, what's that smirk?
- Because, true story.
- It is?
- [Noah] Why don't you
tell them I just Aldis?
- DJ.
- Yes.
- Would you like to navigate this story?
- I'll set it up.
So he-
- I dunno, he's the best.
- Aldis sends in his tape.
He was good enough to send in his tape.
And we all watched it.
I watched it, loved it.
I called up our producers
and Jaume Collet-Serra, our director.
I said, I really think that's our guy.
That should be Hawkman.
And then everyone agreed.
And then, so I said, "You
know, let me call him up."
I've never talked to him before.
Let me just call him up and say,
"Hey brother, welcome to 'Black Adam.'"
That was my intention.
So I call him and I say, "Hey, is Aldis-"
"Hello, is Aldi there?"
And he goes, "Who's this?"
Right away the energy, fun.
Like, "who's this," attitude.
I went, "Hey, this is Dwayne Johnson."
And the following curse words-
(Aldis laughs)
That came out as if it wasn't me.
So then I'll let him take the story.
- So check it out.
Somebody happened had been
crank calling my phone.
Anytime somebody calls
from a random number,
and says, "Hey, is Aldis Hodge there?"
It's either a bill collector,
somebody trying to get my-
who I'm voting for,
or somebody playing with my phone.
So I said, "Look man,
stop playing on my phone.
I don't have time for this today."
We got kids watching
so we ain't gonna get
into the particulars.
I said, "Bro, stop playing on."
"No, it's Dwayne Johnson," da, da, da.
You know, he's being real cool, chill.
I said, "Bro, I'm serious.
Don't play with my emotions."
Day after my birthday, I'm in quarantine.
- I'm feeling crazy.
- I don't have time
for this emotional rollercoaster.
But then he goes into,
"Hey look," da da dah,
"Welcome to 'Black Adam."
Well, actually he
started telling me about,
you know, the tape and all that,
"Saw your tape, loved it."
I thought he was calling to
tell me I didn't get the job.
And you know, boom.
But then he says,
"Welcome to 'Black Adam.'"
And I had a moment where I said, oh.
I legit almost hung up on this man.
Lost the job of my life.
So I appreciate your patience,
you know what I'm saying?
- Yes.
(audience applauds)
- At the same time,
you're not expecting call.
- Who expects a call from The Rock?
Like, you know what I'm saying?
It's outta the blue .
"Hey man, it's Dwayne Johnson."
I'm like, you are doing a really
good impression right now.
- Oh, my god.
- This is not okay.
- True.
- Sometimes you gotta be careful
when you answer the phone.
But I answered my phone and
Robert also does Stevie Nicks.
My hair guy.
And I was inebriated and I answered.
And I thought it'd be
funny to answer with Robert
and be like, "What's up?"
And Stevie Nicks was on the
phone and I was like, "Hello."
"Hello."
I was trying to like not be inebriated.
And then I called him back and I was like,
"You can't just call
someone's number like that."
- Oh, my gosh.
He gave me the tequila.
I blame him.
- Your like, sorry.
I usually sip my tequila...
- Yeah, I was trying
to be so cool about it.
And then by the time I
got off the phone call,
I was like, she's so rock and roll.
Why am I being weird about it?
Anyway, we can edit that out.
There's nothing to do with anything.
Okay, we got one more.
One more.
Oh, for Quintessa.
With the greatest name ever.
"So who do you want Cyclone
to work with in the future?"
#BlackAdam.
- Hmm.
- Oh, interesting.
- I don't know, I don't know.
It'd be really cool to
work with or see Cyclone
in juxtaposition to like maybe Harlequin.
- Nice.
- That could be fun.
- Yeah.
- That could be interesting.
- Write that.
- Well I love that.
Well, the cool thing about our world
that we've all created
here about "Black Adam"
and this universe of JSA is
we believe that all the
characters in the DC universe
can mix and intermingle.
So we should work on that right now.
- I love that.
And that only gets fans excited.
We love that.
We're just like, "Oh, my god."
- Yeah.
- That's so cool.
Great idea.
Okay, so Pierce, this
one's not in the computer,
but what is Dr. Fate's
favorite Pierce Brosnan movie?
Please say "Thomas Crown Affair."
Just makes sense that Dr.
Fate would like that one.
- Ba-boom.
Said it without moving my lips.
There you go.
- Now what would you
say, what would you say?
- "Thomas Crown" is a great movie.
I'm very proud of that film.
- Well, I just mean how trippy it is.
Like, how it tricks, you know?
Like that whole scene in the
museum, it's very Dr. Fate.
- It is very Dr. Fate.
- I sound like a stalker?
(Pierce laughs)
- No, it's a good movie.
And that would be a good choice.
Yes.
- Next time I'm gonna let
you answer the question.
- Well, you're so enthusiastic.
It is your show.
- I'm like, wouldn't it have been nice?
My producer's gonna be like,
so maybe next time let them answer it.
Cool, duly noted.